[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka
die Ereignisse in Russland durchkreuzten
auch die Reisepläne der
bundesaußenministerin einen Tag später
als vorgesehene kam beerbock heute nach
Südafrika der Krieg das Verhältnis zu
Russland sind dort zugleich die
schwierigsten Themen die Haltung des
Westens dass der angegriffenen Ukraine
geholfen werden muss wird im sogenannten
globalen Süden keine Sex geteilt
Südafrika insbesondere die
Regierungspartei ANC hatte historisch
enge Verbindungen nach Moskau und nicht
vergessen dass der Westen das
Apartheidsregime
auch das schwingt mit wenn Europäer und
Amerikaner versuchen afrikanische
Staaten enger an sich zu binden
Meyer hat den Besuch beobachtet
die südafrikanische Außenministerin sie
wartet und wartet geduldig auf die
deutsche Amtskollegin die leicht
verspätet und auch kürzer als eigentlich
geplant nach Pretoria kommt doch die
Begrüßung und der weitere Umgang
miteinander dann herzlicher als erwartet
schließlich gibt es deutliche
Differenzen beim Thema Russland
öfter mal in der Vergangenheit breiten
unterschiedliche Meinungen aufeinander
kein Wunder die südafrikanische
Außenministerin gehört der traditionell
russlandfreundlichen Regierungspartei
einc an der AMC
ist eher ideologisch ausgerichtet was
die Außenpolitik angeht ist traditionell
pro russisch oder pro Putin
ein Grund dafür Westdeutschland
kooperierte mit dem Apartheidsregime die
Sowjetunion unterstützte die Gegner im
Kampf gegen die Apartheid Werburg
verurteilte dies heute deutlich
Westdeutschland Stand zu Zeiten der
Apartheid nicht klar auf der richtigen
Seite der Geschichte unsere damaligen
Regierung kooperierten in
verschiedensten Bereichen mit dem
Apartheid-Regime von heute betrachtet
erscheint das unbegreiflich
immer wieder zeigt bärburg Verständnis
für die Südafrikaner wirbt um Sympathie
und versucht deren Haltung zum Ukraine
Krieg zu verändern ich verstehe dass
dieser Krieg zu Beginn nicht die
Priorität nicht die erste Priorität für
viele auf der Welt war weil die so viele
Konflikte um sich herum ebenfalls
erleben müssen
aber dieser Krieg ist nicht nur ein
europäischer er geht auch Afrika etwas
an Südafrika sieht sich offiziell als
neutral versucht so zu vermitteln der
südafrikanische Präsident und eine
afrikanische Delegation waren kürzlich
sowohl den Russland als auch der Ukraine
legten einen eigenen Friedensplan vor
bisher vergeblich der versuchte Putsch
der Wagner Söldner ändert nichts an der
Haltung
präsidents die afrikanischen Präsidenten
konnten sowohl Präsident silence die
unpräsident Putin treffen vielleicht ein
Ergebnis unserer Haltung es ist derzeit
sehr schwer jemanden zu finden außer uns
der mit beiden Seiten verhandeln kann es
mag Erfolg haben es kann scheitern aber
wir haben uns um Frieden bemüht
wir sollten nicht erwarten dass
Friedensverhandlungen in Paris
Washington oder in Brüssel stattfinden
mich würde es nicht überraschen wenn in
ein oder zwei Jahren dieses in Jakarta
Johannesburg oder Brasilia stattfindet
mehr Einigkeit herrscht bei anderen
Themen wie Klimaschutz oder Handel die
Energiewende in Südafrika unterstützt
die EU mit 8,5 Milliarden Euro bisher
ist Kohle hier der Hauptenergieträger
flächendeckende Stromausfälle sind die
Regel erneuerbare Energien sollen
gefördert werden bisher gibt es sie hier
kaum doch diese Themen wurden überlagert
von der Diskussion um den Ukraine Krieg
auch beim spontan anberaumten Gespräch
mit dem südafrikanischen Präsidenten
ging es dann wohl vor allem um seine
Friedensmission
und die bundesaußenministerin ist uns
aus Südafrika zugeschaltet guten Abend
Frau Werbung
schönen guten Abend sie haben heute
gesagt wenn Südafrika die Stimme erhebt
also sinngemäß dann dann hört die Welt
darauf man sich einen anguckt was
Südafrika bisher zum Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine gesagt hat dass man gerne
neutral bleiben möchte dass man das
Verhältnis zu Russland nicht stören
möchte dass man die Sanktionen des
Westens kritisch sieht das ist jetzt
aber eigentlich nicht das was die
westliche Welt gerne hören möchte oder
mein Besuch hat für mich jedenfalls hier
noch mal gezeigt wie hart diplomatie ist
wie anstrengend auch manchmal aber dass
ein langer Atem sich auszahlt weil wir
im letzten Jahr eben ganz ganz viele
Gespräche hatten auf Konferenzen
manchmal auch etwas Lautstärke aber auch
viel telefoniert hinter verschlossenen
Türen und jetzt eben diese Reise von dem
südafrikanischen Präsidenten mit anderen
afrikanischen Kollegen in die Ukraine
und nach Russland und da hat sich
gezeigt dass ich ein langer Admin in der
Diplomatie auszahlt weil sich die Stimme
Südafrikas aus meiner Sicht schon
verändert hat in dem nach diesem Besuch
nämlich deutlich gemacht worden ist auch
vom Präsidenten Südafrikas und gerade
von ihm dass es eben um die Kater der
Vereinten Nationen geht dass es um die
Souveränität eines jeden Landes geht und
und wie territoriale Integrität das
klingt jetzt technisch aber genau das
ist das Wort aus unserer Karte der
Vereinten Nationen dafür dass jedes Land
das Recht darauf hat in seinen
Landesgrenzen in Frieden und Freiheit zu
leben und das ist neu und das ist glaube
eine sehr wichtige Botschaft gerade auch
aus Afrika hatten Sie denn in ihrem
Gesprächen sie haben auch den
Präsidenten ramafose heute Nachmittag
getroffen hatten sie den Eindruck dass
sie in dieser Besuch in Botschaft in
irpin auch das teile seine Delegation
oder auch sogar er selbst das weiß ich
nicht den Bunker mussten weil das
russischen Beschuss gab das ihm das noch
mal eine neue Perspektive aufgezeigt hat
sage ich mal vorsichtig
ja auf jeden Fall und das ist ja Teil
auch von Außenpolitik dass man an Orte
fährt auch ich werde ja immer wieder
gefragt aber warum fahren sie da jetzt
hin zum Beispiel hier nach Südafrika für
einen Tag weil es eben was ganz anderes
ist als wenn man miteinander telefoniert
wirklich zusammen zu sitzen auch über
Stunden zusammen zu sitzen zu hören wir
sehen das aus unserer Geschichte aus
unserer Erfahrung so Südafrika hat auch
mir noch mal deutlich gemacht damals in
unserem Freiheitskampf dem Kampf gegen
die apartheidt wo leider auch
westdeutsche Bundesregierung eben nicht
auf der Seite der Menschen stand sondern
der Unterdrücker dass damals Russland
sie unterstützt hat das ist was das ist
in ihrer DNA mit drin und sie haben aber
auch deutlich gemacht als sie da in Kiew
waren selber in den Bunker musst oder
den Keller mussten wegen den russischen
Raketen Angriffen dass das natürlich
auch für sie noch mal deutlich gemacht
hat was dieser russische Angriffskrieg
eigentlich bedeutet und sie haben auch
das Wort krieg jetzt benutzt was eben
vorher nicht benutzt worden ist und ich
glaube auch Butcher mir ging es ja
genauso als ich dort in dieser Kirche
stand als man diese Bilder sah von
Menschen die vom Fahrrad geschossen
wurden sind von Frauen die die
Kellertreppe hinunter geschützt worden
sind wahrscheinlich vergewaltigt dass
ein ebenso was nicht kalt lässt und
deswegen ist es aus meiner Sicht so
wichtig dass wir gerade auch als
Europäer mit den Afrikanern mit dieser
afrikanischen Delegation die da war
zusammenarbeiten an einem Friedensplan
auch wenn wir sicherlich nach wie vor
auf manche Dinge unterschiedlich blicken
weil wir natürlich als Europäer viel
Trichter nicht daran sind alten der Wald
vom russischen Regime nun brauchen wir
am Afrikaner natürlich was gewalttätige
Konflikte und Kriege eigentlich keinen
Anschauungsunterricht davon gibt es auch
auf dem Kontinent genug und sie wurden
heute in der Pressekonferenz wenn ich
das richtig gelesen habe gefragt oder es
wurde ihnen vorgeworfen da ist auch mit
dem
verweisen dass sie versuchen würden
Südafrika quasi moralisch zu erpressen
sich auf die Seite der Ukraine zu
stellen was was haben sie darauf
geantwortet
diese Fragen habe ich im letzten Jahr
oft gehört und ich glaube daher war es
wichtig dass wir als Bundesrepublik der
Bundeskanzler und auch ich bei all
meinen Reisen immer wieder deutlich
gesagt haben wir hören nicht nur die
fragen wir hören auch die Vorwürfe wo
wart ihr damals als wir euch brauchten
und mir ist wichtig zum Teil zu erklären
dass zum Beispiel auch Deutschland sich
in der Vergangenheit bei kriegen wie zum
Beispiel beim Irakkrieg gesagt haben
nein wir halten das für nicht richtig
dass wir auf der anderen Seite auch
gerade mit Blick auf die Verantwortung
vor Ort ist ebenso wichtig ist wie jetzt
zum Beispiel in Mali dass wir deutlich
machen wir wollen auch dort dafür sorgen
dass die Menschen in Frieden leben
können wenn uns das nicht weiter möglich
ist dort aufgrund der malischen
Regierung dass wir das Nachbarland Niger
zum Beispiel unterstützen und dass wir
eben deutlich machen es geht uns nicht
darum mit dem Finger auf andere zu
zeigen sondern wir machen deutlich wir
brauchen für den Frieden auf dieser Welt
für den Frieden in Europa viele viele
globale Partner und auch das ist hier
eine Botschaft die ich mitnehme dass die
südafrikanische Regierung deutlich macht
wir Schwüren die Folgen des russischen
angriffskriegs und deswegen wollen wir
zum Frieden auch in Europa mit beitragen
und zugleich habe ich deutlich gemacht
dass wir natürlich auch in Afrika
unterstützen wollen und zwar unsere
afrikanischen Partner unterstützen in
Afrika dort beizutragen dass auch
regionale Konflikte gelöst werden können
in Afrika sind auch die Wagner Truppen
keine Unbekannten alles andere als das
haben sie mit den südafrikanischen
Kolleginnen Kollegen darüber gesprochen
wie diese Ereignisse in Russland
einzuschätzen sind gibt es da
südafrikanische Erkenntnisse vielleicht
jemand in Europa so nicht hat
auch darüber haben wir uns natürlich
ausgetauscht man wundert sich auch hier
9000 Kilometer entfernt von der Ukraine
von Russland von Europa ähnlich wie wir
was da gerade am Wochenende in Russland
vorgegangen ist und da haben wir
eigentlich beide die ähnliche Sicht
drauf dass er manches einfach nicht
erklärlich ist dass es aber
offensichtlich auch zeigt dass Putins
brutale Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
auch das eigene Land auf dem Kopf stellt
und wir haben ja auch gesehen tausende
von Menschen haben Russland im letzten
Jahr verlassen viele davon auch weil sie
nicht gegen die Ukraine kämpfen wollen
und auch das ist glaube ich bei dem
Besuch der afrikanischen Regierungschefs
mehr als deutlich geworden der Schaden
den Putin seinem eigenen Land durch
diesen Angriffskriege zugt Frau Werbung
danke für das Gespräch
danke ebenso schönen Abend noch
das Interview haben wir vor anderthalb
Stunden aufgezeichnet der Wahl ist der
Anführer bzw Vorstandsvorsitzende der
russischen wagnertruppen trinken nach
Belarus ausgereist sagt jedenfalls der
Präsident von Belarus Lukaschenko der
sich heute überhaupt sehr gesprächig
zeigte und von seiner Rolle als
konfliktvermittler und putinhelfer
schwärmte und es irgendwie schaffte
Putin dabei ein klein bisschen blöd
aussehen zu lassen das konnte
Lukaschenko immer schon recht gut trotz
aller Moskau Abhängigkeit
fragt sich wie es nun mit Gregor
Schienen weitergehen wird man ist ja
versucht ihn zu raten von offenen
Fenstern Weg zu bleiben kein Tee zu
trinken und seine Unterhosen nicht
unbeaufsichtigt herumliegen zu lassen
entscheidend ist aber was aus seinen
Truppen wird da gibt es noch eine Menge
Fragezeichen wie MRT sind berichtet
es ist das letzte Bild von ihm bisher
jedenfalls in Roßdorf am Samstag gab
Söldner Chef brigorhin sich den Anschein
des bejubelten der Putin das Fürchten
lehrt wirklich
seine Chance auf eine lange schöne
Zukunft im Ruhestand in einer dartscher
auf dem Land ist gleich null es ist das
ultimative Beispiel was wir bei Game of
Thrones gelernt haben wenn du den König
angreifst musst du ihn besser töten
aber weil brigorchins Schergen eben nur
zielten kann Putin ihren Anführer nun
als Verräter abstempeln und das
russische Verteidigungsministerium
behaupten die wagnergruppe werde ihre
schweren Waffen an die reguläre Armee
abliefern aber wo die stecken ist unklar
was wäre rigorchin ohne sie erledigt
immerhin konnte der Wagner Boss wohl mit
einem komfortablen Jet nach Belarus
fliegen so bestätigt der dortige
Diktator als er den Deal aushandelte so
Alexander Lukaschenko hätten er und
brigoschin erstmal eine halbe Stunde
lang geflucht er sprach von
Gerechtigkeit die wollen uns erdrosseln
wir marschieren nach Moskau und ich
sagte auf halbem Weg werden sie dich
zerquetschen wie Ungeziefer
klingt alles nach Sieg auf der ganzen
Linie aber Putins Auftritt mit den
langen Carls heute wirkt wie das mühsame
Ringen um Deutungshoheit er muss zugeben
dass russische Rebellen russische
Soldaten töteten auch die Bilder von
Rosen die auf die russische Hauptstadt
vorrücken lassen sich nicht ausradieren
eine private Armee die Putin nach
eigenen Angaben mit fast einer Milliarde
Dollar finanziert hat wendet sich gegen
ihn ausgerechnet diese Söldner sollen
jetzt in die reguläre Armee integriert
werden
das sind 15 bis 30.000 Soldaten mit
Panzern Raketen und der Fähigkeit eine
Bande zu bilden die nicht nur gegen die
Ukrainer kämpft sondern auch Russen
tötet
eigentlich müssten dabei Putins
Verbündeten doch Zweifel wachsen dass er
wirklich wieder Herr der Lage werden
kann noch kontrolliert brigoschi nämlich
die wagnergruppe und mit ihren Diensten
in Afrika verdient der Millionen seine
trollfabrik in St Petersburg mit ihrem
Diesel Informationskampagnen ist weiter
eine gefährliche Waffe
putin ist offenbar vorsichtig seine
Strategie ist es nicht zu verschlimmern
er will die Unterstützung in der
Regierung im Militär und sogar in der
wagnertruppe zurückgewinnen deshalb
vermeidet er Vorstöße die zu neuer
Instabilität führen und die sein
politisches und physisches überleben
bedrohen können
die CIA verfolgt nun genau er putines
wagt den Wagner Boss zu beseitigen
räumte zwar am Samstag das Feld aber
seine loyalen Söldner könnten wenn ihm
etwas zustößt ihn Rechen noch haben sie
ihre Waffen
und jetzt erstmal Nachrichten aus
Deutschland von Heinz Wolf
die Zahl der Beschwerden bei der
Antidiskriminierung Stelle des Bundes
steigt stetig im vergangenen Jahr haben
sich so viele Menschen gemeldet wie nie
zuvor das geht aus dem Jahresbericht der
Beratungsstelle hervor insgesamt sind
8.827 Anfragen eingegangen das sind 14
Prozent mehr als im vergangenen Jahr die
Menschen berichteten am häufigsten über
rassistische Diskriminierungen für die
Bundesbeauftragte für
Antidiskriminierung fördermann zeigten
die Zahlen dass noch sehr viel zu tun
ist die Beratungsanfragen bei der
Antidiskriminierungsstelle des Bundes
sind immer nur die Spitze des Eisbergs
und keine repräsentativen zahlen aber
aus repräsentativen Zahlen wissen wir
das Millionen von Menschen
Diskriminierung in unserem Land erleben
und deswegen müssen wir da auf jeden
Fall sehr genau hinschauen und
entsprechend reagieren
das ganze Interview mit förderattermann
ist dann in unserem heute schon Update
zu sehen
Juden und Jüdinnen in Deutschland haben
immer wieder mit Hass und
Diskriminierungen zu kämpfen das zeigt
die Anzahl der gemeldeten
antisemitischen Vorfälle beim
Bundesverband der Recherche und
Informationsstellen Antisemitismus im
vergangenen Jahr zählte der Verband
2.480 Fälle darunter Beleidigungen
Bedrohungen und Sachbeschädigung im
Vergleich zu 2021 ging die Zahl damit um
11% zurück allerdings wurden 9 Vorfälle
extremer Gewalt gemeldet die seit der
höchste Stand seit sechs Jahren
vor acht Jahren ist der dieselskandal
aufgeflogen vor fast drei Jahren begann
vor dem Landgericht München ein
Verfahren gegen Ex-Chef Stadland heute
die Verurteilung zu einem Jahr und neun
Monaten auf Bewährung wegen Betrugs das
Gericht legt Stadler zur Last er wäre
als Vorstandsvorsitzender zum Eingreifen
verpflichtet gewesen laut Gericht hat er
ein Geständnis abgelegt wie auch zwei
mit Angeklagte die ebenfalls
Bewährungsstrafen wegen Betrug das
Urteil ist noch nicht rechtskräftig
die Staatsanwaltschaft Köln hat bei
ihren Ermittlungen gegen Kardinal woky
mehrere Räumlichkeiten unter anderem im
Erzbistum durchsuchen lassen Hintergrund
sei ein Anzeigen in denen wölkey falsche
eidesstattliche Versicherung und Meineid
vorgeworfen werden es gehe um die
Erhellung eines lediglich anfänglichen
verdachtsziel der Durchsuchungen war
unter anderem die Sicherstellung von
Dokumenten geklärt werden sollen workies
Angaben wann er über zwei
missbrauchsverdachtsfälle informiert war
in einer Stellungnahme des Erzbistums
heißt es man bitte die Öffentlichkeit
eine ergebnisoffene Untersuchung nicht
zum Anlass zu nehmen Vorverurteilungen
auszusprechen
alte Hasen oder Herrinnen im Bundestag
hatten es prophezeit trotz allen Dramas
werde die Ampel ihre Hauptstreitpunkte
vor der parlamentarischen Sommerpause
abräumen da geht es ihr wie früheren
Koalitionsregierungen auch schon keiner
hat Lust im September dann wieder bei
Null anzufangen macht auch beim Wähler
keinen guten Eindruck also wurde wieder
mal nach einer langen Nacht heute der
Durchbruch verkündet man habe sich
endlich geeinigt beim Gebäude
Energiegesetz besser bekannt als
heizungsgesetz nächste Woche soll es
durch den Bundestag quasi kurz vor Tore
Schluss was zur Einigung bekannt ist
berichtet Frank Buchwald
kaum ein anderes Gesetz hat Deutschland
so aufgeregt nur dabei hat die Koalition
sich geeinigt das umstrittene
heizungsgesetz soll noch vor der
Sommerpause durchs Parlament die FDP
erleichtert aus meiner Perspektive
heraus hat sich am Ende die Vernunft
durchgesetzt das war wichtig dass wir
hier das physikalisch Machbare und das
finanziell leistbare mit den
Anforderungen des Klimaschutzes in einen
Einklang bringen im
Wirtschaftsministerium müssen sie das
Gesetz nur noch ausformulieren aber das
Wesentliche ist bekannt wer auf
klimafreundliche Heizungen umsteigt kann
auf Geld vom Staat hoffen mindestens 30%
für einkommensschwache Familien bis zu
70% über eine Modernisierungsumlage
können Vermieter statt wie bisher 8 nun
10% der Kosten auf die Mieter abwälzen
wenn sie staatliche Fördermitteln in
Anspruch nehmen Ziel mehr
klimafreundliche Heizungen Vera deal
findet auch die SPD es gilt eine
Obergrenze
wir haben ganz explizit die Mieterinnen
und Mieter geschützt jetzt in unserer
Konkretisierung und zwar das
Mieterhöhungen durch diesen
heizungsumtausch maximal 50 Cent pro
Quadratmeter betragen dürfen auch
Besitzer von Einfamilienhäusern können
aufatmen von Heizungstausch ist keine
Rede mehr funktionierende Gasheizungen
können weiterlaufen dem Gas wird in
Zukunft immer mehr Biogas oder
Wasserstoff beigemischt auch wenn
kommunale Fernwärme zur Verfügung steht
behalten die Netze also ihren Wert das
ist sehr viel weniger als die Grünen
zunächst wollten auch sie aber loben
heute den Kompromiss
wir haben hart verhandelt und es weiß
wert weil wir jetzt ein Gesetz haben was
Klimaschutz auch im Gebäudesektor nach
vorne bringt und die Frage nach der
sozialen Verantwortung nach der sozialen
Gerechtigkeit beantwortet und genau das
ist das was wir gebraucht haben und wenn
wir das jetzt nächste Woche beschließen
ist die Ampel ein ganz großen Schritt
nach vorne weitergekommen nach diesem
Zeitplan soll der Bundestag das Gesetz
nächste Woche abschließend beraten wenn
es noch vor dem Sommer in Kraft treten
soll muss Freitag auf der Bundesrat
zustimmen diese Eile für die Opposition
unbegreiflich nach monatelangem Streit
mutet die Ampel den Parlament ein
wochenendgesetz so wenige Stunden Zeit
um über weitreichende Änderungen zu
beraten das ist zu wenig wir kennen noch
keine Textes ein Blindflug der da
gestartet wird die Ampel aber will das
Aufreger Thema endlich abräumen und
hofft dass damit sommerlicher Frieden
einkehrt unter deutschen Dächern und in
Deutschlands Heizungskellern
und mit Wirtschaft geht es bei dir jetzt
noch mal weiter wie steht der
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland im
internationalen Wettbewerb da für diese
Frage ist unter anderem der Blick auf
die Investitionen hierzulande
interessant weil er realer wie sieht es
da aus nun Deutschland hat als
Wirtschaftsstandort wie es scheint ein
Glanz verloren immer mehr Firmen
investieren lieber im Ausland gründe
gibt es viele Fachkräfte Mangel hohe
Energiepreise zu wenig Tempo bei der
Digitalisierung schwerfällige Bürokratie
und vergleichsweise hohe Arbeitskosten
ja und die Folge zeigt eine Studie des
Instituts der deutschen Wirtschaft aus
der Bundesrepublik fließt deutlich mehr
Geld als im Land investiert wird im
vergangenen Jahr sogar so viel wie noch
nie die Zahlen ins Land kamen
vergangenes Jahr 11 Milliarden US-Dollar
mickrig im Vergleich zu den
Investitionen die ins Ausland wanderten
gut 142 Milliarden unterm Strich sind
damit fast
132 30 Milliarden Dollar Kapital aus dem
Land geflossen auch deutsche Unternehmen
geben dem Standort zusehends schlechtere
Noten laut einer Umfrage des Deutschen
Industrie- und handelskammertages
verlagern deutsche Unternehmen ihr
Geschäft zunehmend ins Ausland Gewinner
hingegen sind die USA deren Industrie
und Investitionen in Fabriken boomen
gerade den Milliarden Subventionen aus
Washington sei dank
vielen Dank
im Zusammenhang mit dem mutmaßlichen
Drogentod einer 13-Jährigen in
Neubrandenburg ist ein 37-jähriger Mann
verhaftet worden er steht unter Verdacht
sehr hoch dosierte exzessy Pillen namens
blue Punisher unter anderem an Kinder
verkauft zu haben das Mädchen war am
Montag im Krankenhaus verstorben zwei
weitere Jugendliche befinden sich
mutmaßlich wegen Konsums der gleichen
hoch dosierten Droge im Krankenhaus eine
14-Jährige ist noch in kritischem
Zustand
zum Sport zum Fußball bei der U21 EM hat
Außenseite und Co Gastgeber Georgien
überraschend das Viertelfinale erreicht
und ist dort möglicher Gegner der
deutschen Mannschaft wenn die es morgen
trotz sehr schwierige Ausgangslage noch
in die k.o-rundeschaft
wird wohl nicht mitwirken können nahm
kleinen Fußballwunder seine
Muskelverletzung ist noch nicht
ausgeheilt seine Mannschaftskollegen
hingegen wollen gegen den em mit
Favoriten England kämpfen bis zum
Umfallen und aus dem Tschechien Spiel
lernen nämlich morgen die
herausgespielten Chancen auch nutzen
unsere Prinzipien die gelten auch jetzt
wir wollen mutig nach vorne spielen wir
suchen auch den Weg nach vorne Siegen
und gleichzeitig hoffen auf die
Schützenhilfe von Israel lautet die
Devise sonst geht's bereits nach der
Gruppenphase nach Hause
richtig bekannt wurde Boris Hermann ja
als er als erster deutscher Segler beim
berüchtigten Wurm den Globe nonstop und
solo um die Welt sehen jetzt war er beim
Ocean Race mit einem ganzen Team rund
100 Tage auf sie auch das ein
waghalsiges Abenteuer es gab Orca
Attacken Risse am Mast und ein
Crewmitglied viel aus der Kohle ja auf
einer der Etappen im Mike knackten sie
mit ihrem Boot malizia ist die Explorer
aber auch einen
geschwindigkeits-weltreppe kommt und
heute zum Finale gelangen ihn noch mal
einen besonderer Kuchen jetzt kamen
berichtet
als die Heckleine der Sea Explorer 3
endlich auf den Ponton fliegt und die
Korken knallen ist die Konkurrenz noch
längst nicht im Ziel das Team Alicia
feiert zum großen Finale seinen zweiten
Etappen Sieg bei fast völliger Flaute
haben sie sich nur wenige Stunden vor
Genua an die Spitze geschoben
90 Prozent der Etappe waren wir hinten
dran und dann haben wir letzte Nacht
einen sehr smarten Kurs gesteuert und
das hat funktioniert und so konnten wir
doch noch gewinnen das macht mich sehr
stolz
der Trick umfasst windstillen Mittelmeer
bestand darin immer ein Stückchen
dichter als der Rest in Küstennähe zu
segeln da gibt's Thermik und die
bedeutet wenigstens ein bisschen Wind
die Geburtsstadt von Christoph Kolumbus
voraus hat die fünfköpfige Kuh rund ums
Skipper Boris hermann ist der Konkurrenz
noch mal gezeigt die Jubiläumsausgabe
des Ocean races eine neue prägende
Erfahrung für Deutschlands besten hoch
Siegler ich glaube das ist verändert
schon mein Leben das erste Mal dass ich
beim Ocean Race dabei bin eine alte
Legende 50 Jahre alt ein
ja eine der
gipfelveranstaltung des Segelsports
31.000 Seemeilen sind sie rund um den
Globus gesegelt sechs Monate lang in
sieben Etappen zwei davon haben sie
gewonnen darunter die alle härteste
durch Südpolarmeer tausende Meilen
entfernt von jeglicher Zivilisation
waren sie ganz auf sich gestellt
du wächst als Mannschaft zusammen du
lernst wie man dieses Boot segelt das
ist viel mehr als nur ein Rennen um die
Welt da geht es um das Team ich habe
Freunde fürs ganze Leben gefunden
das zur siegeehrung des gesamte Team auf
die Bühne kommt ist weit mehr als nur
eine Geste der Höflichkeit von
Bootsbauern über Computertechniker bis
hin zu Medienprofis alle haben ihren
Anteil an diesem rasanten Ritt um die
Welt wir sagen immer 80% des Erfolgs
steht schon vor dem Start der Etappe
oder das Rennens fest es ist
mechanischer Sport es kommt auf jedes
Detail an auf diesem Boot auf jeden
Handgriff alles was um dieses Thema
herum getan werden muss es auch Teil
unserer Performance und insofern ja es
ist einfach ein tolles Gefühl mit diesen
Leuten zusammen zu arbeiten im gesamten
plasmo werden sie auf Rang drei landen
aber als erste Kap Horn erreicht zu
haben und ihn 24 Stunden
Geschwindigkeitsweltrekord das alles
nimmt ihn so schnell keiner mein Leben
hat sich immer am Wochenende glaubt
gedreht und ich glaube jetzt bin ich mit
dem Ocean Virus endgültig infizieren
nach 105 Tagen auf engstem Raum so haben
sie uns erzählt ist es dieser letzte
Sonnenuntergang draußen auf See der ihre
Sehnsucht wach hält schon möglichst bald
wieder abzulegen
das war es von uns gleich nach dem
Wetter geht es mit der Reportage Reihe
37 Grad weiter heute mit dem Thema fast
fashion wie die Textilien produziert
werden die dann bei uns in den Läden
hängen und um 0 Uhr gibt es dann also
heute schnell Update mit Nazan gödem und
uns morgen wieder bis dahin
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die
Oberflächentemperatur der Weltmeere ist
so warm wie nie zuvor und das hat
Auswirkungen aus Wetter zum Beispiel
wenn die Wärme vom Mittelmeer Richtung
Deutschland geführt wird dann kann es
durchaus zur heftigen Extremwetter
kommen so wie letzten Donnerstag in
Deutschland und die nächsten zwei Monate
erhitzt sich das Wasser ja noch weiter
also hier ist noch ein großes Potenzial
dahinter wir schauen auf die
Großwetterlage und da kommt kühle Luft
aus dem Nordwesten oder gab es heute
kräftige Schauer und Gewitter aber was
wir noch sehen sind die Rauchschwaden
von den brennenden aus Nordamerika die
einmal über den Atlantik gezogen sind
Portugal und Spanien erreicht haben und
das Ganze zieht allmählich dann
Donnerstag und Freitag weiter zu uns in
der Nacht gibt es in der Südhälfte viele
Wolken und Regen das zieht aus südwärts
sonst ist es größtenteils trocken bei
Temperaturen zwischen 9 und 15 Grad
morgen muss erst mal der Regen aus der
Nacht im Süden verschwinden dann wird es
Trockner im Osten gibt es einige neue
schaue und auch im Westen gibt es noch
etwas Regen wenn das als verschwunden
ist wird es sonniger und das bei
höchsten Temperaturen von 27 Grad im
Südwesten und zum Beispiel 20 Grad an
der Nordsee die nächsten Tage gibt es
weitere Schauer und Gewitter am
Donnerstag erreichen Sie uns von Westen
her bei 23 bis 30 Grad und am Freitag
überqueren Sie uns einmal nach Osten und
damit ein schöner Abend